it's been a long hard road to the silver
screen for natasha romanov the marvel
super spy with the code name black widow
like any super spy natasha has her
secrets thankfully we've got all the
details of her untold history for you
right here
black widow made her first appearance in
1964 but if it weren't for the name
you wouldn't know it's her not only is
natasha missing her black catsuit and
signature red bob
but in her debut she's not the heroic
spy you've come to know and love
she's evil all the way through in fact
in her debut natasha doesn't even fight
during one of iron man's first
adventures he fought anton vanko a
soviet scientist who's also known as the
crimson dynamo
and then helped him defect to the united
states
stan lee and don heck's tales of
suspense number 52
the soviet union sends the black widow
and her partner the super strong
secret agent boris turjanov to the u.s
to get revenge
while the widow uses her feminine charms
to seduce and distract tony stark
honestly it doesn't take much effort
boris attacks vanko and steals his super
suit
the black widow is a little more active
her next outing tales of suspense number
53 and she gets her own proper superhero
costume and tales of suspense number 64.
although it's a fishnet heavy mask and
cape ensemble not the skin-tight
jumpsuit she's known for today
still during these early appearances
black widow is little more than a cold
war era stereotype
the glamorous and beautiful femme fatale
who uses her looks to manipulate men
into doing her dirty work
it'd be a while before natasha emerged
as a complex capable and fully
independent character
still better late than never you know
black widow's most iconic costume the
form-fitting black suit the bright red
hair those stylish and ultra dangerous
bracelets better known as the black
widow's bite
as it turns out none of those belonged
to her at least
not originally in 1941 a costumed hero
named miss fury debuted in newspapers
comic sections
and her outfit should look very familiar
to black widow fans like natasha
socialite marla drake
slipped into a sleek black outfit one
made out of panther skin in fury's case
when she stepped out to fight crime miss
fury wasn't the first female superhero
but she was the first female superhero
created by a woman
and she quickly gained a number of fans
legendary marvel artist john romita
senior was among those fans in 1970
while illustrating amazing spider-man
ramita learned that marvel had the
rights to the character he told his
spidey collaborator stan lee that he'd
love a chance to draw a miss fury book
someday
and stan suggested that they just make
black widow into miss fury instead
romita traded miss fury's mask for the
black widow's shock of red hair
and the revamped black widow debuted in
the amazing spider-man number 86
the look's been natasha's ever since
black widow was marvel's first female
superhero but there's a catch
she's not the black widow you're
thinking of the black widow that timely
created in 1940 was a psychic named
clairvoyant
yes seriously who lost her life after a
seance went bad
only to be brought back to life to work
as a super-powered servant of satan
himself
in fact her whole gig was killing
evil-doers so her boss could harvest
their condemned souls a little faster
yeah it's real weird clairvoyant only
appeared a handful of times and never
had a regular book to call home
the second widow meanwhile helped kick
off the second volume of amazing
adventures in 1970.
unfortunately the black widow's first
stint as headliner didn't last very long
while natasha strip blended stunning
artwork with pointed social commentary
her amazing adventures co-stars the
inhumans proved much more popular
and the black widow's solo outing ended
after eight installments
thanks to writers and artists like frank
miller brian michael bendis mark wade
and ed brubacher daredevil has become
one of marvel's most popular heroes
especially among hardcore comic fans in
1971 however all hornhead was in trouble
his ongoing book wasn't selling all that
well creatively things were stagnant
marvel originally decided to shake
things up by putting iron man and
daredevil in the same comic but
daredevil writer jerry conway came up
with a different idea
as conway remembered in a 2010 interview
with back issue
i was a fan of natasha and thought she
and daredevil would have interesting
chemistry
i'm not sure what i based this on other
than my desire to bring the characters
together i'm a sucker for redheads
whatever his reasoning he was right to
do it the widow joined the man without
fear in daredevil number 81
and stuck around for over 40 issues she
even got her name added to the title of
the book and daredevil and the black
widow number 93 where it stayed until
number 108
sales rose accordingly and with black
widow as a co-star daredevil
rediscovered its groove
during black widow's run on the title
natasha and matt murdock started dating
and moved to san francisco
allegedly showing an unmarried couple
living together got marvel in trouble
with the comics code authority
when writer steve gerber took over the
book however it meant an
end to marvel's biggest power couple
when matt's best friend
foggy nelson was shot daredevil headed
back to the big apple to help
black widows stayed behind speaking
about the decision gerber said
i didn't miss her daredevil works better
as a loner
in the movies natasha doesn't have any
real superpowers she's just really good
at sneaking fighting and blowing things
up
like any spy worth her salt black widow
has lots of handy gadgets to help her
out
but at the end of the day it's her
training quick reflexes and razor sharp
mind that lead the way to victory
sure about this yeah it's gonna be fun
in the comics things are a little
different for the most part writers and
artists tend to attribute natasha's
superior abilities to her time at the
red room
a soviet training facility one story
however reveals that natasha's got
something a little more special running
through her veins
in 2004's six-issue black widow series
natasha learns that the red room
brainwashed her and 27
other orphans gave them false memories
and injected them with a special super
soldier serum to craft them into weapons
thanks to natasha's chemical
enhancements she heals four to five
times faster than a normal human
doesn't ever get sick and ages much much
slower than she should in addition the
red room developed a special pheromone
spray that prevents its agents from
attacking anyone who's wearing it
a product that nick furies used again
and again to keep natasha in line
while the red room remains a major part
of the black widow's origin story her
superpowers almost
never come up probably to keep the
comics natasha in line with her big
screen counterpart
although we've gotta say the idea that
the widow gets by on her skills and wits
alone is also just much much cooler
four years before tony stark
jump-started the marvel cinematic
universe
tomb raider and kill bill proved that
female action stars appealed to
audiences just fine
and lionsgate wanted him the studio
hired actor and screenwriter david
hayder who'd just
penned these scripts for the first two
x-men movies to bring the black widow to
the big screen
hater's screenplay followed the comics
pretty closely and the writer was all
set to step into the director's chair
when lionsgate pulled the plug
as hader explained in addition to all
those female-led action movies that did
well
there were also movies in a similar vein
like blood rain and
ultraviolet which did not aeon flux was
the last straw
after that failed lion's gate decided
not to go forward with black widow
that's a bummer for hader who loves the
character so much that he named his
daughter natasha
but it's even worse for the widows fans
while natasha finally made her feature
film debut in 2010's iron man 2
black widow stayed a sidekick for over a
decade before finally getting that
long-awaited solo feature
natasha wasn't the first black widow in
marvel comics and she wasn't the first
black widow in the company's cinematic
universe either
although you wouldn't know if you didn't
watch marvel's agent carter which
judging by the ratings you probably
didn't
on the series hayley atwell reprised her
role from captain america the first
avenger
while offering fans a glimpse inside
shield's predecessor organization
the strategic scientific reserve as one
of the ssr's only female agents peggy
carter must battle sexism in the
workplace
while also doing her best to topple
leviathan a soviet espionage agency with
eyes for howard stark's genius and
deadly inventions
throughout the show carter butts heads
with a leviathan assassin known
only as dottie underwood who serves as
peggy's evil counterpart
and who also happens to be the mcu's
first black widow
this is my surprise face agent carter
never actually uses the black widow code
name for dottie but if you're paying
attention it's clear
and even if you're not paying attention
the show's producers later came out and
confirmed the connection
like natasha dottie is a product of the
red room training program
they even fight like one another once
actress bridget regan realized where
agent carter was taking her character
she studied scarlett johansson's fight
scenes in order to make sure that both
spies had the same style
at first joss whedon and black widow
seemed like a match made in heaven
whedon rose to fame as the steward of
complex and compelling female action
heroes on shows like buffy the vampire
slayer angel
and firefly and his geek cred is beyond
question
if anyone in show business could get
black widow right fans seemed to think
it'd be jaws
at the time of the first avengers movie
scarlett johansson seemed to think so
too
speaking to cbs news she said joss did
not want the black widow to be the
damsel in distress or just another
pretty face or someone that was you know
a woman that was incapable of holding
her own
she just throws down and sweeps the
floor and when i read it it was just
like oh thank you joss
things worked out pretty well for the
first avengers movie second
not so much how'd a nice girl like you
wind up working in a dump like this
fella done me wrong in age of ultron
natasha gets a lengthy subplot dedicated
to her budding romance with bruce banner
and at one point she stops to explain
why they'd make a great couple
he's a monster she says because he's got
the hulk lurking inside
of him she's a monster meanwhile because
the soviet scientists in the red room
sterilized her while transforming her
into a super spy robbing her of the
ability to do her motherly duties
you still think you're the only monster
on the team that's a story point that
straight out of the comics in which the
red room's super soldier serum turns
women's bodies against their own wombs
but fans still weren't thrilled with how
the scene seemed to reduce a fascinating
character to the sum of her reproductive
parts
they let weed know about it too in the
aftermath whedon quit twitter and later
tried to explain that the monster line
was referring more to natasha's past as
a cold-blooded killer than her
infertility
but it was too little too late the
damage had already been done throughout
the marvel cinematic universe we've got
only glimpses of black widow's past
life as a russian assassin but it's
clear from those glimpses that her early
years were far from easy
she was recruited trained sterilized and
taught to kill without mercy and she
eventually managed to overcome
all of that to be a hero in avengers
endgame natasha must reckon with both
sides of this existence
she notes early on in the film that she
had nothing before the avengers she
thinks of the team as her family and as
her reason to keep trying to be a better
person
even in a post-thanos world when natasha
and clint barton are dispatched to
vormir to get the soul stone
we learn via the stonekeeper aka red
skull that her father's name was
ivan this is significant because it's
information not even natasha herself
knew until then
she was so ignorant of much of her
family's history that her own father's
name was a profound revelation
reminding her of where she came from and
the redemption she was seeking to earn
through her heroics check out one of our
newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite comic book superheroes are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you